Just lumped up Eurobed clinic. Their approach is something called the George Protocol after Dr. Frank George
Which combines insulin-potentiated chemotherapy, which is chemotherapy given with insulin so that the
Cancer cell would uptake the chemotherapy a little bit quicker and they could use 10% dosage
With powerful homeopathic immune modulators specific to each patient's cancer. Well, that sounds
The light following that sounds like a great approach. So if a person wants to do chemotherapy, but doesn't want to do
Hydro's chemotherapy that insulin-potentiated chemotherapy is a different option and a good option
Anytime you're using the specific only apathic, that's a even a better option is that
But you got to weigh all it out. You're going to probably have to move
Down there for three months because typically of course of insulin-potentiated chemotherapy
At least 36 months
So just got away all that I would if that's the right thing for you, but all means look into that